welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name is hisham azuz
today i'm really excited to be joined by
david jenkins who is the managing
director of vertical advantage and also
the founder and director of nurture
talent vertical advantage was launched
in june 2012 and over the last nine
years they have solely focused on
serving the fmcg and consumer space
recruiting from everything across sales
marketing to logistics and procurement
they're currently there's kind of 16
people within this brand and they have
three more people joining the company in
january
in september 2019 david launched nurture
talent with andy davis they offer an
embedded talent solution and
subscription pricing model where they
partner with scale-ups who want to hire
quickly and effectively now this isn't
david's only recruitment business or his
first so before this uh before launching
both his businesses david actually
started another recruitment business
where he received vc funding from james
khan in 2009 but after a couple of years
david exited this business and sold his
shares on the company
despite adversity
both businesses both brands
um he's been really pleased with
the growth the year
they've had and i know david is going
into 2022 excited optimistic
um as he plans to achieve more growth on
both these brands so david welcome to
the podcast welcome to the podcast thank
you thanks for having me
looking forward to this there's a lot
of cool there's a lot to cover
uh so
where i always like to start is the
million pound question which i'm sure
you thought a lot about
as a leader of a recruitment business so
love to hear your your thoughts on this
so i'd love to just hear your take on
what you believe
are the traits characteristics that
really make up a
successful high performing recruitment
consultant in today's market today's
market okay
um
the first thing that i would look for in
in any recruiter at any level is urgency
i think it's one of the most difficult
things to actually test for in an
interview scenario
to try and work out how urgent somebody
is how they deal with things how quickly
they they work
and
you can kind of it's it's something that
with every exceptional biller that i've
ever kind of met come across at any
different level they're always they they
just are always on it they're always
really really sharp they're always
moving from think from from one thing to
another but they know if they need to
pivot and they need to kind of to
to change they'll do that quickly and
you know we could talk a lot about a
number of different traits but i
honestly put urgency at the very very
top um
the other bit i think that
in is more relevant today than it was
five eight ten years ago is
the recruiter today
needs to be
one-third sales person relationships
one-third
hr and understanding human psyche
behaviors
culture what makes a good cultural fit
and one-third marketeer being able to to
not only to to be a sector expert to be
but to be able to position yourself as a
sector expert um and to be able to talk
really really freely both you know
online openly on on linkedin or you know
via blogs or emails or and actually
provide that real added value being that
sector expertise couldn't agree more how
how have you got better
looking for urgency in an interview
because i'm sure it's something you
continue to think about if it's that
important to you
well we've we've done a lot of crowd
hiring this year okay we did we did a
lot we did a lot of analysis um when we
were kind of coming out kind of q4 last
year we did a lot of analysis over the
previous three or four years of everyone
that we hired all the levels the
salaries we paid them how they performed
what they built what the roi was et
cetera et cetera and we kind of just
realized that ultimately
we were we were getting the best roi and
the best development from the people
that we hired
as as either grads or second jobbers but
they hadn't done recruitment before and
they wanted to commit so we've done a
lot of that this year
and
we within our um interview process there
we set two tasks okay they get through
so i interview everyone first of all i
receive all the cvs i i look through
them all
anyone i like i email immediately and i
deliberately have an email conversation
with the person and i see how quickly
they come back
come back to me on email
so the quicker they come back to me the
better a sign it is that i want to put
that person in for a call quickly
so i'm already starting to make a
decision on what their what their email
community i'll ask them something
spurious in the email just to see how
they respond um you know sometimes
people put like make
stupid mistakes or they say some
something silly in the email that's a
bit of a turn off but still go through
with the with the call we have a quick
20 minute to half an hour call if
they're punchy and reactive on that call
i'll book them in immediately for
a zoom call with my commercial director
but again i'll introduce them on email
and i'll leave it to them to book the to
the interview themselves
so i want to see i want to see that they
are driving the process then at that
stage i like it we'll we'll obviously
send the zoom invite so all the way
through the process we're trying to see
like how on these people are
and then when we get them to the
interview we put them through a you know
a fairly
fairly rigorous probably one to one to
one and a half hour interview and then
we do we have a couple of tasks and
exercises so we give them a job
description six cvs tell them to to give
them 15 minutes come up with the best
three in order reasons why they're the
best three and then we ask them to write
an email selling in those candidates to
a client and we give them another 10
minutes to do that and if they can
achieve all of that as a grad with no
experience and recruitment they could
get through it
okay i feel like that's been refined
over time over time taking a while to
get there i like it it's still a working
place yeah still i don't know i like the
subtle sort of urgency to i like that i
think that's great because i think it it
should give you a real insight into what
that might be like
i mean if they're not urgent for
themselves how urgent are they going to
be for another human being you know 100
100 you know people you know i have had
people come back to me you know after
three or four days saying oh thanks for
your email like let's book in a call and
i you know and at times i'd be like well
sorry you missed the boat that's not
quick enough yeah and i know that sounds
harsh but
like it's what we're looking for yeah
yeah
so interest just just
just curious just as we're on this topic
so obviously you've
done more uh grad hiring this year
what
what um so you've spoken a bit about the
interview process just keen to get your
thoughts immediately really on speaking
to a lot of recruitment companies over
the last couple of months and yeah real
real challenge is hiring for their own
companies i mean it's always been a
challenge but for most companies i speak
to they're really they've really got
back this year to hiring that trainee
and if i'm honest i think
most people i speak to they actually
prefer
that that's what they want
but
typically a lot of companies i speak to
are always open to experienced hires but
i think this year that's been really
difficult just because
i mean if you're half decent you should
be making some good money this year with
with the sort of um how sort of crazy
the job market is
so yeah i guess what i wanted to ask and
just get your immediate thoughts on was
speak to a lot of people who just find
it really difficult and they're just
like
what what advice do you have what people
you speak to that have worked hard on
getting better at getting in front of
grads or selling to grads or attracting
grads and could you share with me so i
don't know if there's anything that
you've learned this year that maybe
you've seen have a direct impact on the
amount of sort of attraction you've got
from grads or that that type of talent i
have interest
yeah it's it's an interesting one i and
i wonder when you when you
talking to people about that and you ask
them about that process i i the main
change that we've made this year
is that i've driven it okay
the owner of the company that's the
owner so if most people are saying well
you know the biggest thing i want to do
is hire more people the biggest thing i
want to do and then you say well
who who's doing the interviewing it said
oh it's the senior consultant or it's
you know it's our talent manager or you
know and i get it business is bigger far
bigger size than us they need to have
that structure and that thing but for me
i will always you know regardless of
what size we get to and that's you know
let's hope we're sitting here in a year
or two's time and we're at least double
the size where we are now
um
but for me it will always be the most
important thing that we do and it's
hugely important for our culture and i
think it's helped us to
you know to win when we've when we've
been competitive with grads we've had
three or four offers that i've had the
engagement with them from the very very
start and i'm not saying they're joining
because of me but always i've been able
to then have a relationship with them
where i could pick the phone up and say
look i think you can make a balanced
decision these are the things where i
think we'd be a great fit for you but i
could totally see why these other
options might be things you want to
consider as well
um
so so personally driving it is one and
then actually on the overall attraction
bit
i think the people on grads
people are
not paying attention
to grads on linkedin enough yeah so
grads like right obviously we're
advertising will advertise on all the
main job boards and linkedin and stuff
like that most that's that's not rocket
science but lots of grads in their last
year are on linkedin yeah for sure
and and they're
you know like if they're anything like
me they've no clue what they want to do
so again some really really we we've
actually hired three grads from
loughborough and we've hired three grads
from bournemouth and if there's no doubt
in my mind like i love my sport and
whenever we meet people who are into
their sports there would be the football
whatever whatever it may be
they you know that that's just something
and you know we've got five side
football team and we do kind of some hit
stuff yeah so it's just a trade of a lot
of the people in the business so we
target people at those universities who
are in their last year at uni and we try
and connect with them find out what
their plans are etc and if they know
anyone else who's looking and we also
get our grads to go back and talk to
people at the universities and see if we
can get ahead of the game a little bit
there as well final thing on that just
really quickly
curious what what do you think grads of
today actually want
from your perspective like what do you
think they're motivated by just from
your conversation because i think this
is again this is probably where you've
had to adapt i feel like or recruitment
companies have had to
think about what they articulate
communicate
what do you think
we're talking we're talking about this
yesterday
uh yeah yeah we i was chatting with some
of them yesterday one of our directors
went off on um maternity leave yesterday
so we had a little mini baby shower
online and there but then we ended up i
ended up having a chat so i was still
talking about a couple of these fires
that we've been making
and
i i honestly think
that the culture is now the most
important culture
yeah i
honest honestly do i think it i think
for grads
it you know
obviously everyone's different but
i see more of these days coming in
saying i want to work for the right kind
of business going to be the right fit
for me me as an individual
and whereas you know a few years ago
money would have still been top of the
list would have been you know earnings
earning potential
i think i think a very very close second
actually is career progression and
development um and there and you know i
get asked that question pretty much in
every interview that i do with a grad on
that first call is you know if that's
usually the the second or third question
that i get but usually the first
question is is called character nice
thanks for sharing
so let let's get straight into the the
juicy stuff david if that's okay let's
just let's just get straight into it
let's just get straight into it nervous
because you've you've um
yeah i mean look you've been in
recruitment for
nearly 20 years
yeah there's a lot right so let's just
get straight into it so
where i want to start is is this this
journey that you went on with the vc
side of things let's start there and
then we'll really unpack the last sort
of decade basically
okay so obviously bar that for anyone
obviously i've got davis linkedin up
here but obviously before that you
worked at recruitment for five years
progressed the director before you you
did that right so i guess firstly i
guess firstly like what what was you
hoping
raising investment would enable you to
do when thinking about starting
recruitment companies so what was it
that you was hoping it would enable you
to do with it enable you to sort of grow
at pace would enable you to grow it like
invest in the best techs immediately
invest in people i don't know what was
you hoping it would enable you to do out
of interest
yeah but you know what the sort of the
the two main things from that actually
stem from my prior year with the first
business that i worked for so actually
joined there in 2002 seven years
actually from the test director level i
sat on that board of that business which
is a really really nice business we grew
it to about 80 people at its max i sat
on the board with with three other
people the nd and two and two others
and we'd have board meetings that last
the entire day
and a lot of the stuff that we would
talk about i just couldn't believe that
we were talking about it like going into
the minute detail of the change of price
of stationery from month to month would
be an example there was a slide on that
in the board
you know and you know and i was like
this
but this is the like the guy who set up
that firm was the next senior consultant
for michael page so he'd never he'd
never he was a self-taught md
all the other people who joined that
company were grads that had worked their
way up from grad to exit so our learning
journey as a as a board was basically we
were a bunch of recruiting consultants
that grew up to be directors of yeah
just learning on the job yeah exactly
that so actually
for me the investment piece was great
because it enabled us to grow at scale
it enabled us to to get to higher that
you know we set up in april 2009 which
is a probably i would akin to like
setting up in january of this year you
know just just as markets coming out of
a crash
really really brilliant time to start
hired lots of great people
so the cash was great from that
perspective but for me personally it was
the learning journey i wanted to learn i
was a good recruitment director all
right i've had a team of 20 people
across three offices i was a decent
operator a good pillar not the best
builder but a decent builder
and but i wanted to learn how to run a
business i wanted to learn what a p l
was what every line of the balance sheet
meant i wanted to learn like what payout
rate was what roi was and i felt james
khan and the team that he had there
they've been it they've done it i would
learn loads so it was a twofold journey
of a a learning piece and also you know
hopefully we're going to grow scale
something that you know going to sell in
the future and you know buy a small
island off the caribbean you know that
would be
as you can tell from my backdrop but you
know i did get i did get the learning
yeah no i like that okay thank you so
what
always interested to hear so for anyone
listening that may be considering going
down that route for maybe other reasons
but
what was like
what did you learn or what ended up
being the most crucial part that you had
to communicate when convincing people
like
james khan and his vehicle as to why
they should back david like what was
really crucial because if you said it
was a learning i'm assuming you've never
put together an investment deck before
or a business like so like what ended up
because i'm sure that was learning so
what ended up being
really crucial looking back
that you think i don't know yeah
anything important around that
yeah i think
like with with with them like we were we
were coming as a team so there was there
was six of us starting so they you know
it was nice to have you like to be able
to they have the trust in me that i was
bringing five pretty experienced pretty
good people with me on the journey and
that they believed that
i they could all report to me and i
could be their md
so that was that helped yeah and that
was that was obviously compelling but
that's not a necessity certainly if
you're looking investment i honestly
think with with the whole with the
that whole
convincing someone to invest in you you
have to be true to yourself you have to
be you know you can't kind of pick
things kind of pie in the sky you have
to be honest with you have to be honest
with
like where you are where you are in your
career what you what what you need
and then what what is achievable so
don't over egg it basically yeah so but
but also i look there there are some
standard things being being in good
markets being in growth markets being
able to spot where niches are and where
development opportunities are and again
with that business when we were pitching
to james we could we could call out
this was 2009 right we were able to call
out in retail
e-commerce is going to absolutely fly
right so we were able to call out we can
target the likes of neta porter asos et
cetera etc they will be amazing clients
and we can really really over index on
that and you could see that there were
really really good growth opportunities
in various other pockets of the market
and that really really helped i like
that
so i mean
share with us what you what you can
but like i guess people are interested
and keen tonight i'm sure you've been
asked this question before
yeah of course like how how was the deal
structured because i think this is where
sometimes people can be a bit worried
because i think the perception yeah
i know people i speak to i think
obsession can be quite a negative one of
going down the investment route they're
going to take all my money and all this
still feel employed like what how did
how was it structured out of interest
like did you was you the majority
shareholder would you not
james was the majority shirt james and
and the vc business were the majority
shareholder so they were about
66 and we were you know we were the
remaining 34. i was the second highest
shareholder and you know invested our
own cash
so yeah ratchets that if you do this yes
and right yeah i'm ratchet ratchets to
grow to get to to get to a higher left
to get to a higher level and we to be
fair ratchets that were achieved so
it wasn't uh you know it wasn't an
underperformance thing as to why it kind
of evolved the way it did it was more uh
you know
board to nd kind of thing that
it was
more probably more appropriate that i
moved on took my money out of my shares
and let somebody else come in because
ultimately i think my
learning journey there had stopped yeah
and i really wanted to be the majority
shareholders
yeah
it was it was it was going to be
impossible to make that happen in the
time scale that i wanted it to happen so
that's kind of why i ended up going but
you know
i think the
learning there is i wouldn't put anyone
off getting investment i actually think
it was an incredible thing to do but
it's doing it for the right reasons
if if you're if your plan is to grow
rapidly scale or your plan is to
you know to live a kind of a certain way
or a certain lifestyle and it doesn't
mean it doesn't dictate that you need to
be 100 shareholder i think the
investment is is a really really good
route to go down yeah i think yeah that
i was going to ask you advice but you
you've known that it's just yeah anyone
listening that's considering going down
that path like really really make time
to think about why
um
and yeah it's something it is true i
think that that's really what it boils
down to and one once you have clarity on
that then hopefully you'll be able to
make the right decision or better
decisions
um
i guess just quickly final point on this
just to wrap this up just because i
think it'd be useful what were the were
the with the ratchets like were they all
similar just different targets or was it
around like a nephew income what were
the typical ratchets out of interest
that could be interesting yeah yeah it
it was netflix income and ebay okay nice
super simple yes so we yeah we had to we
had to maintain a minimum of a 20 margin
and then we did a three-year budget
forecast so basically the ratchets kind
of went along kind of as as they came so
yeah and we you know
we we achieved those and that was that
was great but i think the
the
the it's
the input level where you've got kind of
a vc business and then you've got a kind
of you're you're you're always pushing
right yeah you know you'll see it in in
any industry right
it's growing it's growing it's growing
and then sometimes that's not the
the most sensible thing to do with the
business sometimes there are times where
actually you shouldn't be hiring you
should actually just be letting people
bed in or doing different things but
you know in that kind of scenario it's
pressure pressure pressure to do it and
actually then you're making decisions
which aren't necessarily the best
decisions for the business because
you're trying to hit a target you're
trying to hit a number you're trying to
hit a ratchet and it's like well
we we've got to do it but actually
you know that that's what i mean about
like getting the the right investors and
the right support for when you're but
thinking about what you want to do with
the business longer term because
actually you don't want that support to
then impact how you're going to run your
business
so what so vertical advantage so like
talk to me about i feel like i'd be
interested to know when when you thought
about vertical advantage in the first
instance like
what was top of mind for you i think a
lot of people would then go into
launching their own recruitment business
and be like right i'm going to do this
differently i'm going to take that which
i liked i'm not going to do that what
was like david's mindset towards sort of
approaching vertical advantage
differently out of interest
well the the first thing was there was
140 clients i couldn't touch for a year
so
yeah so yeah yeah yeah
typically people would experience
but you know i was getting paid out on
shares and stuff like that so it was it
it was and it was a prescriptive list
right so it was every client that the
business had had an interview with in
the previous year wow okay was it was
was so it was basically i just so so i
knew who i couldn't go after which then
made it quite easy actually to go okay
that's fine
so
i sat myself in
like i i had been off the tools for
about 18 months in terms of recruiting
day to day so it was great to give
myself six months to just go and do that
build some clients build some
relationships make a few placements etc
etc before starting to kind of scale it
um
so i guess
the
i i think i just took i took the view
that again there were some niches within
some of the spaces that we were
operating in that we were
would have been great growth areas and
we would have pushed kind of further
desks on i just kind of focused on those
so things like crm data analytics
insights
we which is you know a hybrid part of a
kind of a marketing department really
but we weren't really really focusing on
those i really really pushed that in the
kind of the early stages and then the
scaling kind of of the fmcg consumer
piece and what vertical advantage really
stands for is that we wanted to be a
sector specialist that had specialist
individual recruiters across these
different areas that we hire into so
supply chain procurement logistics yeah
sales marketing digital et cetera so we
could go to any client
purno ricard revlon bracket bankies or
whoever it may be and say look
you could put us onto your psl and we
will have a specialist in each of these
individual areas that can cover and
we're we're a niche specialist for you
but also you can use this across the
board so
you guys get economies of scale and we
can probably be your boutique recruiter
alongside your michael page your haze or
whoever you want as your you know your
top tier major supplier and that
is still the premise of us today and
that's still that's that that still
works we've just got more people and we
become more specialized yeah yeah
why why do you think like i hear this so
i hear this so much this is always
interesting to hear people's take that
just spoke to so many people now on the
podcast where they've they sort of
sometimes people will go i wish we went
niche more sooner or we'll talk about
that you're talking about that it's
actually your differentiator or it's
really important like i don't know what
from your perspective a modern day
recruitment bit like why is that so
essential why is that so critical
to
a a modern day recruitment business to
have those niche
but i don't know why is that important
from your perspective be good to your
take on why that's important
yeah it's um
do you know what it is it's that
just the modern day of recruitment and
the modern day of how businesses want to
engage
in attracting talent and their evp so
there's so much more today
that is out you know the internet social
media et cetera et cetera this glass
door there's all these things and
businesses are so so cognizant of their
own brand and it's really you know
people can go on to twitter or you know
trash abruptly whatever it is right they
can do it so
it starts there really
and actually then when they start
thinking about their suppliers and who
they want to be their representatives in
the marketplace they don't want somebody
who's going to be uber salesy trying to
ram jobs down people's throats or
anything like they want really really
credible
really really bright individuals who are
understand a their business be
understand the types of candidate
they're trying to attract and see handle
them in the right way treat them like
human beings
and i think that that is how recruitment
has evolved today and it's a far far far
more professional industry than it was
when i start when i joined in in 2002
and that is why
new specialization is so so important
for for anyone and you know
like if i could have another 20 people
in the business would still continue to
do the same things that we're doing we
just keep segmenting again yeah
well
just on this really quickly just again
interesting your thoughts
what sort of what sort of key markers do
you look at or indicated you look at
that sort of
gives you the the feels of this could be
a big area this could be a big growth
area
i'm trying to yeah just interested in
your thoughts on that not trying to give
it to get you to give all the secret
sauce away but
what are some of the typical key markers
that you look at that go you know what
that could be a really interesting area
that could be its own market itself
those things
a couple of different things um
so i'll give you i'll give you actually
easier to probably give it as an example
within our business so within e-commerce
and digital we separated that out from
our sales and marketing team a couple of
years ago because we realized that
brands wanted to you know wanted to sell
their products directly to us they
didn't want to sell them in the
supermarkets or whatever it is and then
and then we realized that brands were
actually selling
a lot more of their products on amazon
standard right like but there's loads of
it like there's mom-and-pop brands in
amazon that are like you know selling
golf branded golf balls or whatever it
is picture frames and they're making a
couple of million quid so we kind of saw
this kind of trend happening and
obviously ridiculous growth rams and
everyone kind of knows about that and we
basically just saw this ecosystem of
businesses happening around amazon and
marketplaces
i basically just said we are going to
just we're going to get in there early
we're going to basically be amazon
specialists we're going to focus on on
just talking knowing understanding
amazon being able to like our lots of
literature about amazon candidate
attraction so that
when when businesses go to search for
amazon recruitment or recruit
recruitment experience now like we're
we're coming up yeah we're
our people are there
now other businesses have caught on to
that of course they have it's you know
it's no secret that they've been
billions and billions of pounds raised
by businesses just acquiring brands that
sell on amazon so that always happens
um
but we got there early yeah so we're
ahead of the game we've got the brand
we've got the space in there so it's
easier for us to execute and and there
were probably three or four other areas
now i can personally see
in our space that are going to be super
super impactful like there's a lot of
legislation about reducing sugar content
in products so you know think about the
impact of that the impact of climate on
food
these are things in the next 10 years
are going to shape what products we buy
on our shelves sustainability so we're
already positioning our new desks with
what's coming for us yeah so is this is
this very much just uh
just just being super curious
committing to your industry being
embedded in your industry asking good
questions speak like networking speaking
to people and then
yeah just like just yeah i guess she's
being smart really with what you're
reading what you're taking in the
information that you're looking at
yeah absolutely like my guess my guess
is you talk to loads of tech recruiters
yeah you've probably got a really great
network so you know in tech there's new
stuff going on there all the time right
news new stuff going on and new new
different things being tried etc etc so
again depending on whatever industry
you're in i think as a leader and as a
recruitment owner you owe it to yourself
to be the most knowledgeable person in
the room about what's going on in your
industry yeah yeah
because if you do
then you can see and spot the trends you
might you might spot a competitor doing
something that looks quite interesting
and then you might be able to jump on
the back of that it's not if you know
there's no shame in doing that but if
you're also the first person there and
can recognize the need coming before
anyone else does
that first mover advantage is huge yeah
i love that thanks for sharing that so
obviously as i said in the introduction
so soon to be um
correcting me if i'm wrong here but
you're going to be just around 20 people
in january right yeah okay cool yeah so
common question that i i get and i know
we're just jumping around a bit here the
common question i get
is typically and i don't know if you can
relate to this but there seems to be
like a real
it can be like a real challenge for
recruitment businesses to get past that
like 10
head cut mark
and then sort of build that sort of
critical mass that enables them to go
from
yeah 10 15 20 et cetera so i guess i
don't know if you could talk a bit about
some of the challenges that you've had
to work through
in in getting i know it's not just about
the head count but in terms of like just
building a good group collective of
profitable i don't know like what's been
some of the challenges in breaking
through that 10 head count mark and and
did you experience any challenges
experiences
far too many child we can have a whole
podcast just on the challenges
yeah that's not just recruitment that's
just generally yeah yeah
no no no being serious um
yeah you're you're right and it is it is
difficult 10 is 10 is a is is an
important number but also with with when
you're going past 10 yeah
you're also making a difference in terms
of
you know your cost base your the way
your business is you know you're making
decisions proper business decisions for
pretend you've always got the
opportunity to be
push it back to your lifestyle business
retract to six or seven
move everyone remote you know
that can happen if you lost one or two
people yeah make that decision once
you've committed and you've gone to 10
12
there's a bit more reality about the
direction of traveling you're going now
luckily i i've never i was always going
this way right i was never it was always
trying to get here as quickly as we
possibly could and you know i'm actually
pretty disappointed we're only at 20
people in january given the age of the
business but you know firm plan that
we're going to accelerate and catch up
on where i'd like us to be in a couple
of years time
but but i think that that
main challenge or or how like how do you
get through it
is
is when the times when the times are
good and the times that you know when
you've got the opportunities when you've
got the good performers when don't sit
don't sit and rest then right that's the
time to really push that's the time to
re when you when you're tracking your
job volumes and your job volumes are
strong you're tracking your conversions
and your conversions and your ratios are
strong that's the time
to have your own
you know your own kpi in place your own
your own saying okay i've hit that now
like some people will call it a higher
interest some people some people will
look at it from a financial perspective
whatever it is but have that in place
stick to it be dedicated but push
through and i think you can't do it just
bit by bit one at a time you've got
you've got to really really try and make
the jump because it won't all work you
will step back a little bit so then
you've got to be pretty tough about your
decision making because i said it's
become a bigger business
how important is it like if you think of
like your job now do you think
do you think you stayed too close to the
tools for too long was that was that a
part of it or was it just not was it you
just had to do that anyway i don't know
i was too nice it was too nice
yeah i like i i
i just like i i like hiring people that
i like
what said did you keep even a business
that maybe you shouldn't
yeah and probably experienced recruiters
that ended up going into in-house jobs
and things like that would be far better
in in those in those worlds but like
them got on well with them maybe work
with them in previous businesses
whatever it is and they're far better
doing what they're doing now but because
we got on well and there are good people
like we we i held on too long and
actually i had to you know i'd have a
word of myself in
2018 into 2019 about toughening up
otherwise you just weren't going to kind
of get there and i had a non-exec at the
time
recently evolved but he he would hear
the same chat with me he was kind of
like look you're going to have to decide
here what you're going to do yeah you're
either going to have to really really
push on but you're going to have to top
it up toughen up on some of your
decision making or
you can just crack on as you are and
everyone can be friends but you're going
to remember 12. what is it what is it
that you i don't want to say struggled
with but what was it that was it sort of
maybe i don't know what was it just that
you're just an overall nice guy or you
don't want to let people down did you
feel responsible for these people like
you knew like what like what
i mean yeah i mean you probably
i'd like to say overall i'm a nice guy
and that's why
you know what it's difficult when you
when you've seen people do well and
perform and you know they can perform to
a level and you believe in them and you
like them as people you want them to
succeed you want you know you want to
try and help them to succeed and you'll
do everything in your power to help them
to get to where they should be or where
they've been before
but some but it changes instead the
market changes people changes their
needs wants motivations desires they all
change and actually
you can only control the controllables
i'm sure loads of people have said that
on these on the podcast so and it's very
so true but actually
you do have to toughen up you know if
you're gonna be a business owner you're
gonna you know you're gonna be looking
at what your what your cost base is
every month and it's going up 60 grand
70 grand 80 grand like you if you're
gonna run a successful business you you
have to you have to make those decisions
and like
i make those decisions and we make those
decisions now but i also have a
leadership team that
probably takes some of those decisions
away from me sometimes yeah and kind of
say like i'd be like let's try this so
let's try that and they're like no we've
got to do the right thing we're moving
we're moving on and we're we're going to
make this decision
not exactly you mentioned that oh it's
been a real
it's been a real popular
message that i've had this year
which i find really interesting because
i i do feel like i've recorded it hasn't
i've recorded like a bit of a sort of
short video series and like key insights
from from this year's conversations and
one of them is absolutely
like i don't think this will come as a
surprise to you from sort of our
interactions and stuff but i do really
believe that the modern day recruitment
business owner the most successful
recruitment business owners that i've
spoken to are have way more humility
than they do ego
so i think it makes sense the fact that
most messages like i've had so many
messages going hey you're connected to a
lot of people do you know any good
non-execs decent because they're willing
to ask for help they don't feel like
they know all the answers so you
mentioned one example there so one when
did you get when did you engage in
non-exec and where was the sort of
driver motivation behind that i mean it
makes sense the fact that when you went
down the vc route you wanted that
learning so clearly you're someone that
was willing to ask for help um yeah
how do you go about finding that person
yeah okay yeah good good good questions
a hundred percent believe in the in the
non-exec and advisor route and i made a
mistake when i set up vertical advantage
not getting a a non-exact same okay
because i thought like yeah cause i you
know okay 2012 2013 i'd had a lot of the
learnings and i felt like great i'm
equipped now i've you know i've done my
10 years i've done two recruitment
businesses i know what i need to know
i can i can do this so i did it for
three years got us to about 10 people
across two different offices there was a
little bit of that back and forth 12
yeah back eleven and i was a bit like
okay how do i get through it and that
was where i went and so and sought the
help and i
i asked every single supplier that i had
who was involved in the recruitment
industry who they knew and who they
recommend i did linkedin searches and i
went i probably met about 15 different
people over a six-month period
what was it that you looked for that was
important to you i know this is a nuance
but what were the sort of
important things for you out of the
just someone that didn't just like
they're the best one in the world there
are some people in the well
maybe speaking of the recruiting
industry there are some people in the
recruiting industry who do a lot of
talking but don't say very much
right so
there was a lot of that kind of chat and
it's a lot of like up in the air and
strategic and this and that i actually
really really wanted someone who was
going to be really really honest really
really direct said something in one
sentence that they would you know they
wouldn't waste saying it in three
sentences they just tell me how it is
and i don't have time to you know kind
of red personality i don't have time to
kind of to have
four-hour meetings when we can do
something in an hour i'd rather i'd
rather we were kind of to the point we
moved on yeah and we have those
conversations so was that there was a
style match point i was looking for i
was looking for the right kind of person
the right kind of style and and the guy
i settled upon didn't know anything
about our industry he had a fairly
corporate kind of background but a
global kind of background um
and he'd been doing advisory for a
couple of years but he was really really
interested in what was going on he was
really interested in tech he was really
really interested in markets he was
interested in international recruitment
and he was
yeah he he had a good story himself but
he he'd seen a lot of different things
in a lot of different sectors and that i
thought was that was great and he was he
was exceptional but we also worked
together for five years and became too
comfortable yeah and he
when we parted ways earlier this year we
both agreed it was the right thing to do
i love that because again
learning journey had finished because we
worked together for five years we were
good mates but
yeah that's you've been too nice again
mate
there you go it keeps coming back for
that we need to rename we need to rename
this
so what so then so i know you said it's
evolved so then if you've got a new
exact now and you're not exactly yes how
what was important this time i think
because i think like now you're a
different business what was important
now that you was looking for out of
interest that was important to you yes
so because we've got it's actually
important that we because we've got two
businesses yeah and
one's really really someone who could
work with both businesses okay and
i i i liken selling nurture as a
proposition is a bit like
um selling a sas product yeah it's a
it's a solution-based sell you're asking
someone to commit far higher amounts of
money
and it's not like contingency
recruitment or even a retainer it's it's
a lot more kind of complex than that so
actually
when we're thinking about evolving this
we wanted someone who could actually
really really help us advise us on a
solution-based selling proposition
so maybe you come from an rpo background
or a technology kind of background but
again also on the recruitment side of
things so the guy that we found actually
started just on the nurture business for
six months and then he started to pick
up the va stuff um
how did you find them yeah
um again recommendations so we and we
use a recruitment specific accountancy
firm yeah and the ceo of that firm i've
got to know well over the last few years
and yeah again similar similar process
to it to how i went before asked all my
suppliers asked all the people in
industry probably these days is now a
little bit easier to find those people
because they're all on linkedin networks
you see a lot of people doing talks and
stuff like that we've got a good
training provider so i asked him who he
he rated um nice and yeah again yeah i
found him that way
so okay cool so before before we finish
and i wanted to ask you around that [ __ ]
so this is one of the other insights
that i've taken it's interesting you
mentioned so
one of the other things that i've
definitely noticed this year is um
like definitely a rise in
solution
selling
i would say so i don't know if you've
noticed this but i would definitely say
that
like i think in the last 12 18 months
it's definitely enabled or encouraged
recruitment companies to think about
their offering
and how they could evolve it
um and something i've definitely
noticed more and more of it is this like
talon partner model
um
which seems obviously a bit similar to
nurture talent so i guess
interested to hear so i get i feel like
the common hypothesis that i get from
people and speak to people about who've
done this or considering it is
like instead of working with david who
has a business that wants to go from 10
heads to 15 25 heads just read series a
funding whatever
instead of speaking about ones and twos
freezing forwards every quarter or
whatever
let's speak to david around how we can
actually support his business for six to
12 months
and we're going to agree what the
deliverables are on the hiring side
um each month we're also going to help
him shape their hiring process because
that needs some work um understand
what's possible what then he's look for
these types of things and instead of
paying per person per person you're
going to pay us x per month and there
might be some deliverables in there
where if you deliver four or five people
then you get you get an extra
increase in terms of monetary or
whatever but what that means for david
is he's got a dedicated talent partner
the hiring problem should hopefully be
solved he's got a dedicated person going
out there every single day talking about
their brand they're building out their
hiring process that could be useful for
people in the future and he saved the
money he saved the money
yeah like that seems to be the typical
you should be ahead of sales you've
nailed it but that seems to be like the
hypothesis so like how but i do feel
like there's different challenges in
this from when i spoke to people that
are doing that
so like how is it actually played out
because that hypothesis makes sense a
lot it makes sense doesn't it so david
you can save money you're going to work
like did it do all that but like what
what what has been really difficult
about out of interest like what when
when actually executing
because the trust trust is this
is the is the big thing so you're asking
some it's very very easy to give a
recruiter a job on a contingency basis
yeah because you're paying your spending
yeah exactly right you know even pay him
a small retainer up front or whatever it
is you spent a couple of grand whatever
it is
still right it's it's but you're then
trying to convince someone
to maybe part with
60 80 100 grand over a six-month period
and they've got nothing for it before
they've committed to it they haven't got
anything for it and it's that you're not
selling them a piece of technology you
know you can show them what it's what
it's like and you can show them case
studies of how you've done it really
really well before but that person needs
to trust you and needs to believe that
you can deliver what you say you're
going to deliver and actually
off more often than not at some point if
they've got ceo or founder level they've
been burned by somebody in recruitment
at some point in their careers they've
got a pre-interception and their trust
trusts already broken for a lot of
people
exactly that so you've got to try and
get your head around that now if it
would it really really helps if you sell
a concept that is like nurture so
something as a service this is talent as
a service you can call it that so if
your product or something you sell is
similar and you your product is also
part of a supply chain you're basically
saying look recruitment is part of your
supply chain it's part of your dna it's
just one component part of you building
and scaling this business you might
outsource you know you you're not going
to hire a chief legal officer are you
you're going to outsource your legals to
a law firm you're probably not going to
hire a cfo day one you're going to
outsource source during expert it's just
the exact same thing
it's just an outsourced part of your
supply chain and it's not a direct
overhead right so you're not paying
national insurance you don't have to
employ someone if you're not happy with
it you've got a 30-day notice period
so you're trying to give them comfort
in terms of of where they are but you
also need to be compelling that actually
you've got good quality you're
delivering good quality so the people
that you line up to talk to them about
who their talent partner is going to be
need to be impressive yeah they still
need to be able to sell themselves they
need to be good recruiters and
so these are you know there are a lot of
component parts but it's also it's
incredibly rewarding yeah it's basically
it's basically from a if you can if i
can liken it to anything from the
recruitment agency side it's basically
like working for your best client what's
been the biggest challenge that you
least expected
i think the biggest challenge is
is that is the door opening piece okay
it's the it's the
like how many proposals a month for for
new business can we actually get out you
know we've got beauhurst and you've got
linkedin and you've got techcrunch and
you you know you can track and you can
see where people are
but getting hold of pete you know just
because someone's raised 5 million quid
and they need to hire 50 people doesn't
automatically give you the god given
right that they want to talk to you and
hear about your service right you think
this is amazing they're going to be spot
on for this and you know it's an
e-commerce business something we know
inside out we're like this surely is a
no-brainer and they're like no you know
don't even want to have a conversation
so i think we underestimated that a
little bit but we're also getting a lot
better at how we
sell into those businesses you know yeah
we've got growth hackers in in these
businesses and you know
entrepreneurs and residents and
basically they're just people who are
working out within you know growth tech
firms how we grow more how we grow
quicker how we sell more and actually we
need we've needed to adopt that kind of
mindset of how we develop business isn't
the traditional recruitment methodology
we need to get away from that
we need to get to more of a solution
selling model yeah so look come to the
end here i want to get to recent times
and then sort of find out a bit about
what's on the horizon for you guys and i
know there's still so much we can talk
about right but i guess obviously when
we're preparing for this i know that you
mentioned that i hope you hope you don't
mind me sharing this but again correct
me if i'm wrong but obviously this
you've experienced nearly 80 growth on
your nfi
so i guess what just to keep it recent
obviously we've had all-time high job
markets but yeah like what like what
would you what would you say has really
contributed to
that was like
i'm sure you're spending a bit of time
looking at this year now thinking about
it as well as next year but what do you
think of some of the fundamental things
you did right this year that really
enabled you to achieve that figure do
you think
i honestly think it's what we did right
last year yeah that's made us do well
this year
i think that the recruitment market has
been good we all know it's been good i
actually don't know if nearly 80 growth
is where that sits in the overall market
for business of our size if that's good
like as you said yourself most
businesses
should be growing should be growing at a
good level i think i'm i'm really really
proud of what the guys have achieved
this year and we're you know we're
really really happy with that we've got
another plan to do something similar
next year
but
it's it definitely stemmed from how we
how we manage things from april to
december of last year that's what's
enabled us to get it to where we are
what did you do right
just do the right things support when
you could like what was it we just over
indexed on helping really just went i
surprised david
again comes back the nicest guy in
recruitment i keep on labeling myself
but you know
you know in all our sectors we created
spreadsheets of open yeah um
open spreadsheets of candidates who are
have been
displaced in the industry and where we
noticed that we noticed that people were
hiring directly and there were relevant
people on those spreadsheets we'd send
those spreadsheets to clients and say
look at this list these are all people
who are active market contact them
directly it's not a fee it's not
anything we know you're hiring there's
some really really good people in here
so we basically did a lot of free work
for for probably a three month period
yeah and we'd had a brilliant q1 so that
was great and then
then we were able to really really
monetize that i think a couple of our my
senior people stepped up
ridiculously in terms of their networks
their market how how they were able to
impact
took things on their own board one guy
started his own kind of podcast series
with a guy in new york who was working
in a similar market and it was talking
about the difference between the us
market here
didn't ask him to do it he just did it
he did a brilliant job got him brilliant
traction in the marketplace so
i had
so like thankful that i had a brilliant
senior team but also
we just just went out of our way to be
nice to do the right thing which we
possibly could yeah i tried yeah because
it was pretty horrendous for everyone
well i i do really i do really feel like
that really resonates with me and i do
really feel like i do feel like this
will play on recruitment i think in the
in the long term but i do feel like
like being nice isn't a typical business
owner business person trait
but i think that should change and i i
do think i think that will change and i
do think empathy compassion
doing the right thing being a good human
are absolutely brilliant business traits
and i do think that'll change i don't
know that just really resonates with me
just because i think the journey that
i'm on like so far and and that it does
play out but i think it's when you're
like you you did those things not
because you're like in two in 24 months
time we're gonna do five deals with that
company you're doing it because it feels
fundamentally right in your bones to do
it to do the right thing
and yeah the way the world it it then
comes yeah it comes back round right
background right so yeah
absolutely absolutely and yeah you know
there is all those you know those
different things around you know
business owners needing to be you know
tough and harsh and you know there are
times where you've obviously got to make
difficult decisions
and
i'm not a i'm i'm not a believer in that
but what i am a massive massive believer
in is is really really understanding
people
and i think to like with the way of the
world today with mental health with
physical health with the way that you
know you cannot grow and scale a
business in the recruitment industry
without being really really interested
in your people and what's actually going
on in their lives outside of the
day-to-day because
if someone's sleeping badly they're not
gonna be they're gonna they're gonna
struggle to recruit properly if
someone's eating badly they might have
it could be experiencing some healthy
like it's all completely interconnected
and if you weren't interested in that
kind of stuff
today the future you're gonna really
really struggle to grow and i think
that's that's fundamental in terms of
building a business now and these and
maybe not just recruitment other sectors
as well so what what let's wrap up them
what what's on the horizon for va then
what are you uh excited about talk to us
talk to us next year what's going on
super excited we
we've done a big big piece with the new
knight exec on further divisionalising
okay so all these new all these new
hires so probably most of our guys are
probably working across three or four
different skill sets at the moment
that's going to go down to two so all
these new new so we'll be slimmed down
so we probably segment out probably
seven or eight different areas that
we'll really really focus on some are
growth areas some are more core areas
and so we've got a we've got to take
that to clients we've got a new client
management strategy in terms of client
reporting and and being um more
connected with our clients we've got to
build on that we've got some new tech
coming in and new phone systems coming
in early part of next year it's going to
be interesting but that's going to help
we're hybrid working so we're three days
in the office two days from home yeah
and a couple of people have more
flexible contracts so we need to again
gear up for the future by investing in
some really really good tech around that
and so there's some of it some of the
things but like honestly i you know that
over
all of that the the thing that i'm most
enjoying most looking forward to getting
the my teeth into is more growth for
both of the businesses because we've got
amazing opportunities to continue
growing and i love like i love hiring i
love seeing the business grow in terms
of head count so i can see it's going to
be an exciting year i love it well david
thank you so much continue being you my
friend continue being nice thank you
thanks for uh thanks for being so honest
and there and then sharing everything
yeah really excited to share this over
everyone so yeah huge thanks for coming
on the podcast
no worries thanks mate cheers